- Une fois de plus, André
Boisclair reste muet devant
les caméras en arrivant au
palais de justice de Montréal.
L'ex-chef du Parti québécois,
ancien ministre, rase les murs.
Il s'engouffre dans la salle
d'audience, sachant qu'il y perr
purgera deux ans moins un jour
de prison pour avoir agressé
sexuellement une personne
avec l'aide d'un tiers et
pour une agressiexexexuelle
sur une autre victime.
Il aura, à sa sortie, deux ans
de probation où il devra éviter
de s'approcher des victimes
et n'aura le droit de consommer
aucune autre drogue
que celles sous ordonnance.
JÉRÔME LAFLAMME, procureur,
poursuites criminelles, pénales
- À mon avis, une peine
de deux ans moins un jour reste
quanêêême une peine importante.
Donc, ça envoie le message
que ce sont des gestes graves
et qui sont punis à la hauteur
de leur gravité.
- Le juge a souligné
le courage des deux victimes
qui ont porté plainte
contre le politicien connu.
- Les plaignants sont venus
témoigner sur la peine.
Ils ont livré un vibrant
témoignage des conséquences
que les gestes ont encore
dans leur vie aujourd'hui. Donc,
on remercie le tribunal d'avoir
porttetetention à cet aspect-là.
- Le juge a justifié la peine
par le début de prise
de conscience du délinquant.
CHARLES CÔTÉ,
avocat-criminaliste
- On a tenu compte des facteurs
favorables à l'accusé, à savoir
qu'il a entrepris une thérapie
par lui-même avant d'avoir
à ce qu'on lui impose.
Il y a eu des suivis pour voir
si le résultat de sa thérapie,
sa sobriété, était respecté.
Il en a fait la démonstration
par des tests sporadiques
qui ont été dés s s en cour.
- Le juge croit qu'André
Boisclair représente
un faible risque de récidive
pour la société.
- En étant une personnalité
publique connue, bien, je vousde
de la sentence, il va la purger,
mais pendant très longtemps,
parce que sa carrière
personnelle, professionnelle
en a pris pour son rhume.
- Pour les centres d'aid
aux victimes d'actes criminels,
la peine est raisonnable.
KARINE GAGNON, Réseau des
Centres d'aide aux victimes
- C'est quand même une sentence
significative, donc on espère
que ça va aider à la confiance
des personnes victimes envers
le processus judiciaire.
- En plaidant coupable,
Andrisisisclair a ainsi évité
deux procès au système
de justice, mais il a surtout
éviter deux procès aux victimes.
Par l'entremise du procureur,
elles se disent soulagées.
Et elles espèrent
que l'emprisonnement
de leur agresseur accélèrera
leur processus de guérison.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau
Radio-Canada, Montréal.